macht
in der maske
weil die hotel in bern swiss press award
margrit sprecher wird mit dem preis für
ihr lebenswerk ausgezeichnet
ihre oft kritischen immer von einer
persönlichen haltung geprägten
reportagen beeinflussen maßgeblich den
schweizer journalismus margrit sprecher
ist 80 und arbeitet nach vorn
wie macht sie das und was für ein mensch
steckt hinter den zeitungs texten
davon handelt dieser film
ich kenne margrit schon seit 25 jahren
damals war sie redakteurin bei der
weltwoche und ich habe für sie
geschrieben
heute mache ich einen film über sie und
begleite margrit zum ersten mal bei
ihrer arbeit und in ihrem alltag
ich habe gedacht ich kenne sie gut doch
die drehtage wurden für mich zur
entdeckungsreise
schon am ersten tag stamme ich heute
geht margrit auf eine reportage nach
berlin
doch sie nimmt gar kein gepäck mit nicht
mal einen kleinen koffer ich verreise
eigentlich seit jahren nur noch so ich
will über haben möglichst ganz leicht um
kurz durchkommen darum dass sie sind
meine standardausrüstung für süden oder
norden westen und osten passt immer
margret porträtiert einen kollegen einen
der bekanntesten einflussreichsten und
umstrittensten schweizer journalisten es
ist sonntags blick kolumnist und ringe
spitzenmann frank meyer
zuerst zeigt der markt seine wohnung
einmal pro monat haben wir hier gäste
aus politik kultur wirtschaft die ich
hier bekochen
die ganze dekoration und der schmuck und
alles diese wohnung und die einrichtung
ist meine frau bitte nehmen sie brachte
mich aus bedingungen und der einzige
mensch der mich wirklich nicht beengt ob
schon wir jetzt 35 jahre zusammen sind
das ist frei ja die habe ich nie denkt
er und sie sehe auch nicht ich sie
vielleicht schon
ich bin ja dann doch ein macho relativ
autorität
natürlich diskutieren wir enorm viel
aber die muss ich immer durchsetzen was
ihr gelingt was ihr gelingt hoffe ich
bin erstaunt wie offen frank meyer über
sich spricht dabei ist margrit für ihre
spitze feder bekannt ich frage ihn was
er sich von diesem porträt erwartet ja
wir bestimmt dinge die mir nicht
gefallen weil dinge die mir nicht
gefallen weil das normal ist das gehört
dazu weil marc beckert eine außensicht
also und dann habe ich sie ja immer
gelesen und auch gelesen wie spezi sein
kann das ist klar
das ist mein flügel und nach dem
interview frage ich margrit ob sie schon
weiß worauf ihr porträt von frank maier
hinauslaufen so kalt wäre ginge ja klar
dass man nicht die meiste interesse mir
eigentlich dass du unterschiede
diskrepanz zwischen sinne einmal er
aufwendige lebens ließ und ihm linke
gedankengut
doch im ganzen interview konfrontierte
margrit frank maier nie mit ihrer
eigenen meinung das mache sie nie sagt
sie mir auf dem rückweg
sie suche keine konfrontation sondern
ein gespräch
sie bleibt immer freundlich wie schreibt
man danach trotzdem kritische texte
geschickt wurde zum werbetext leben über
dem link sondern um der leser möglichst
ehrlich so wie nie so lebte und dann
muss man einfach ein schritt zurück
machen und segen denn wenn jetzt nicht
schuldig dämonie interviewten oder der
womit schickte ein zu mini job machen
und das hilft den meisten sehr zum
mittelstand klären
am gleichen tag fliegt margret nach
zürich zurück bereits im flughafen
beginnen sie zu arbeiten wie immer
irgendwie im gedächtnis sein zimmer
gebucht plätze werden aufwand schieben
locken können sie haben wieder in diesen
oft sind sie allerbeste deshalb
beflügeln oder so viel lücken so vieles
in bewegung ganz oben bewegen
magaths arbeit führte sie rund um die
erde vom büro bis island von südafrika
bis japan durch die usa und ganz europa
ihre reportagen sind fast immer porträts
von menschen aus unterschiedlichsten
welten kampfpiloten und fotomodelle
prostituierte und hausfrauen zum tode
verurteilte und topmanager entstanden
sind dabei an die 1000 reportagen und
rund ein dutzend bücher
es ist furchtbar es sind alles zufall
gesehen ihr geld weg artikel und auch
gerne behauptet artikel von mir alles
weg aber die belorussen
das ist das einzige was mark reid vom
eigenen sachen aufbewahrt hat dass ich
die fcs sich gerne mit zwölf jahre und
sie heißt es unerfindlichen gründen
apotheker zeitung inka jannik warum
schweizer apotheker zeitung sogar an die
redaktion unter dem kopfkissen
kinderzimmer und ich bin halt macht die
hand der druck macht mit kohlepapier
zwischen mehr als acht stück an ihnen
können drucker miteinander detektoren
todesanzeige schrieben sogar rote
sicherheitsgurte schau az xi wo
glückspost
für margrit war immer klar sie wollte
journalistin werden
doch in der schweiz der fünfziger jahre
war das kein frauenberuf realisiert hat
sie es beim schulabschluss beim
berufsberater mache den kocher
sekretärin von der chefredaktor werte
margret spanisch und portugiesisch
gelernt und arbeitete danach zwei jahre
in einer aluminiumfirma das ist das
gebäude wohnflächen aller unglücklich
stieg sie um ihr leben und zwar sind
zweite stockte sind genau dort ihr büro
die hannover setzte gemacht und das ist
vorstellbar aluminium baron und
bauträger und weiße tücher und wir
riskierte nicht so gefällt allerletzte
markets begann ein publizistik studium
in münchen
doch es war ihr zu theoretisch sie brach
ab und ging zu einer presse agentur in
zürich artikel wurden verkauften sollen
an lokalblätter hochzeits beilagen hätte
dass kreis und der beste bett inhalt
oder lieblich geranien oder also also
theilig sache halten
die nächste station war l hier machte
market etwas was damals zu einer
frauenzeitschrift gar nicht passte
sie begann kritische reportagen zu
schreiben schon ihre erste über
einsiedeln als wallfahrtsort löste
entrüstung aus der hauptinsel entthronte
alle inserate zu streichen
margrit musste ins kloster einsiedeln
zum gespräch ein fotograf nahm sie beim
warten auf auch später lösten viele von
marc rich artikeln kontroversen aus
protagonisten drohten mit klagen lisa
warfen ihr hervor
das lob wie fälle kühlen es genügt wo
der satz gehässig und herablassenden
finden die andere für einen preis
geteilt und seien wir denke ich aber nur
höflich umgang also es geht es in
standardsätze andere leser wurden zur
fangemeinde
markwitz name wurde bekannt trotzdem
verließ sie nach zwölf jahren l
warum wollte ich wissen wie arbeitsweg
hätte durch berg für drei magnolia blöd
einmal kastanien als normal dokument
magnolia blühen
also ich kann nicht noch einmal eine
schöne bequeme sind alle froh als sie
ist
1981 wurde margrit leiterin des ressorts
leben heute in der weltwoche
daneben schrieb sie regelmäßig weiter
des interviews mit dem fellini und der
sich im gazastreifen daran die reportage
machte über weil ich die menschheit also
phase als größte freiluftgefängnis auf
der welt und es sich eine familie
traurigste reportage sie prallen wz
göttin bombardiert
67 danach unterstützte margret jahrelang
finanziell drei palästinensische kinder
später auch ein brasilianisches mädchen
magazin patenkinder im alter von 50 bis
14 jahren
eigene kinder hat margrit nie bekommen
obwohl sie und ihr mann sich das eher
gewünscht hätten
merkels ehemann guido wird war
videokünstler vor 15 jahren starb er
sie waren 35 jahre zusammen noch während
der dreharbeiten erscheint im schweizer
journalist markus porträt von frank
maier journalistisches spitzentreffen in
berlin untertitelt die redaktion den
beitrag und wie erwartet es steht nicht
nur schmeichelhaftes drin
heute besucht margret das gefängnis
verließ oft porträtiert die menschen auf
der schattenseite des lebens sie will
sagt sie ihnen stimme und gesicht geben
sie trifft einen gefangenen der wegen
drei banküberfällen und ausbrüchen 38
jahre haft absitzt
da kriegt schreibt schon das zweite mal
über hugo portmann
unter anderem geht es um ein heikles
thema das psychotherapie angebot für
gefangene mit einwilligung zu einer
therapie dürfen laut bundesgericht
vollzugslockerungen verknüpft werden
hypoport man hätte gern die
vollzugslockerung doch eine therapie
lehnte er ab zwei bundesräte und die
eins zurück geschickt danach zdf ist
mache das resultat wohl mehr wird teilte
das gab verbands geschichte zumindest
als gutachten machen verspricht madrid
stellt sich in dieser frage klar auf die
seite von hugo portmann auch der neue
text wird nicht ausgewogen sein
das sei gut für analytische abhandlungen
meint sie eine reportage müsse einen
persönlichen blick haben
subjektive möglich sie eher stehen hätte
zuschauer diese möglichkeit den eigenen
standpunkt diese kann sich der konvertit
könnte genau so ist es aber möglich
bis zur matura die porsches und so muss
es sondern er kann selber erzählen zum
schluss konnte zu einer meine heute
arbeitet market nicht ich fahre zum
ersten mal mit ihr nach chur in ihrer
heimatstadt ihr verhältnis zu graubünden
verstand ich nie sie schimpfte immer wie
eng und konservative sei trotzdem ist
sie ständig dort hingefahren zum
skifahren um freunde zu treffen oder um
ihre mutter zu besuchen
sie will mir ihr kurz zeigen
sie führt mich auf ihren lieblings wegen
zu ihren lieblingsorten nur auf eins ist
sie nicht gut zu sprechen auf ihre
vorfahren auf die sprecher von benny sie
sagt ihre patriotische herkunft bedeutet
ihr nichts sie hat auch das von nie
verwendet
doch ich überredet einen bau anzuschauen
der einst ihren vorfahren gehört hat
zusammen fahren wir zum dorf calw reisen
sie ist vorher noch nie hier gewesen
kein problem
die burg die seit 500 jahren eine ruine
was denkt sie hier über ihre vorfahren
wenn du als irgendjemand den
wassertropfen ihr tröpfle blutverdünnern
den sächsischen mensch verwirren das
lebensgefühl vor dem wie ich das dauert
sei und ins tal apparaturen nach maliks
erhält man der stadt den bosch wie
celtic sie und im sommer heiß also sind
so gedankenspielen wäre es auch für sie
ein ort zum wohnen
alles muss
es gibt aber in chur ein haus an dem
market hängt ihr elternhaus stoffel ist
der neue die neuen bewohner stoffe durch
maxi stoffe
hier ist market aufgewachsen hier lebte
ihrer mutter sie wurde 101
nach ihrem tod vor zwei jahren ging das
haus in andere hände sich so lustig 14
andere name der stadt und ganz seltsames
gefühl
hallo mama ich war ja enthoven von allem
ich meine von von der alltag war hier
eigentlich weit weg ist ein anderer
alter ja es war ein hafen das ist
eigentlich das wort
es war ein hafen zu dem man immer
zurückkommen konnte indem man in
sicherheit war wie man nichts passieren
konnte und das hat wahrscheinlich mein
leben erleichtert dass mir alles immer
so gut kann immer wichtig sie leben
immer in der minute in der sekunde sogar
denken wir zurück den kölner fans
wirklich jetzt ist sie stets und überall
es gott ist kurz das diw also was will
man mehr